[音楽]
ブードゥー君
[拍手]
[音楽]
na na na na na
ana
[音楽]
ni
voodoo
あっはぁっ
ああああああ
goo
pa
[音楽]
ana
[拍手]
[音楽]
えっ
あああんだ
[音楽]
ani
aname
ああああああ
知っています
me
amaran
ani came
[音楽]
ben
ran
[音楽]
ああああああああ
par 4
[音楽]
ああああああ
スプーン osan
voodoo
中古車
ban
[音楽]
た
n ame
ni
san
bef 2
[音楽]
me
dee
pa
[音楽]
cap
ana の
amaran
ああああああ
[拍手]
[音楽]
n ame
ありがとうございます彼が拓哉超人私が言うとビーツ2人合わせて超人ビーツと言い
ますどうぞよろしくお願いします
ありがとうございますそれでは僕も少しだけですがお話しさせていただきます
ですねほんとにまあ日本はですね昨今ダンスブームで本当に日本縦断さあ人口ですごく
増えているんですよ
その中で僕たち超人ビーツはちょっと変わったチームとして活動させていただいており
ます何が変わってるのかって言うとですね
僕たちは面白そうなことは全部取り入れる
とえそういうモットーのもとに活動しているチームでございます
例えばジャグリング例えばヒューマンビートボックス
例えばのマジックパントマイムなんでまぁのおもしろそうやと思ったものはですね
全部取り入れてダンスと混ぜてみたりとか
もしくはそのダンサーならではの解釈で
再構築して新しい姓をつくってオリジナルのショー作って利用させていただいており
ません
もちろんうまくいかない時もありましてさまざまな試行錯度トライ&エラーの中で
いろんなものを作っています
具体的な例を言うとですね
あの例えば僕らの皿回しって皆さんご存知だと思うんですけども
佐橋がまずむっちゃ面白いんちゃうかと思った時期がありまして
7皿を買いまして
ものすごい練習をして皿を回せるようになったんですよ僕ら二人とも
でちょっと前にあのダンスと混ぜてに予報って思ってむっちゃ練習したんですけどまぁ
一切混ざらなかったという
そういうこともございましたよそんな失敗とかの中で試行錯誤の中で
結構本当に誰も見たことないような新しいものが生まれたりとかして
そんな感じでパフォーマンス活動を続けておりません
本当に最初に言った通りあの日本ですごいダンサー人口も多いし
ダンスのスキルも世界的に見ても凄い高いんですよ
その中で僕たちがステージに立つ意味っていうのは何かなっていうのをちょっと考えた
時にですねまぁ僕ら二人でしかできないものをそういったものをですね皆さんにご提供
というか
弘前できるいただけるそんな存在がある
いればいいなと思って活動を続けておりません
超人筆っていうのはダンスチームの名前ではあるんですけれどもそれだけではなくて僕
はあの新しいダンスのジャンルやと思って活動させてもらってます
ダンスをベースにとにかく面白そうな物っていうのは混ぜて
作った全く新しいパフォーマンスこれが超人ビーズだと思っています
今日は皆様に後短いショーですけれどもあと2つだけ
演目をご披露させていただきます
一つはダンスとジャグリングを融合した
ちょっと面白いものと面白いものを掛け合わせて作ったオリジナルのパフォーマンス
そして
一つは逆にそういったギミックをすべて取っ払って
ストリートダンス自体の面白さっていうのをフューチャーした作品これを2つ続けてご
披露したいと思いますみなさんにあの
楽しんでいただくために作った賞なので是非
クシュとか盛り上がりどうぞよろしくお願い致します
ありがとうございます
それでは拓哉超人準備よろしいでしょうか
まいりましょう
ええええええ
[音楽]
あああああああっん
f
スプーン
r
me
んはぁっ
ああ
スッとん
[音楽]
f
を see
[音楽]
ています
[拍手]
[音楽]
wh
ああああああ
[音楽]
goo
ああああああ
me
[音楽]
ああああああ
はぁ
あああああああああああ
[音楽]
bloo
jr
ああああああ
[音楽]
ああああっあぁああああ
ああああああ
[音楽]
me
ああああああ
a 3
me
tee
ああああああ
[音楽]
goo
na na na na na
me
ああああああ
ran
ええええええ
barena
[音楽]
reblog
ています
me
ana
can あの
ni
ああああああ
ana b 4 dna
befor
tee
あああああらぁぁ goo
rar
wh
me
あぁぁああああああっあぁああああ
ああああああ
明日やるなら
vivo ティティーボウ
dj だった
dere
nu do
あああああっ
[音楽]
goo
aname
ana
danejones
パワー no nai
[音楽]
ana
rejet あの
dj
car
[音楽]
me
n ame
goo
[音楽]
tp ぼん
goo
rar
pou dou dou
too
[音楽]
[拍手]